SPEAKER: Today, we're talking
about Apigee X, baseball
and BigQuery, AI workshops for
free, and ML inspired candy.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
To help customers globally
scale API programs,
we're pleased to bring the
power of Google's networking
capabilities to API management,
Apigee X. The latest release
of Google Cloud's full lifecycle
API management platform,
it makes it easy and simple to
apply Cloud Content Delivery
Network, CDN, to APIs.
Working in tandem, the two
solutions-led enterprises
not only secure and
manage their APIs,
but also make them available
across a global ecosystem
of stakeholders.
With the start of
baseball upon us,
learn how BigQuery
helps scale and automate
insights for baseball
fans and businesses alike.
And while baseball serves
as a fun playground,
parts of the
process outline here
can be used across all
industries that have big data
and want to turn it into timely,
contextual, succinct bits
of valuable information with
vastly improved efficiency
relying on automation.
Google Cloud is offering
no cost training
opportunities to help you
gain the latest AI and machine
learning skills.
You'll have a chance to learn
more about the new document
AI along with explainable AI--
Looker, BigQuery ML,
and Dialogflow CX.
Check out the blog
post to register.
It's tough to resist
candy, and even tougher
to resist the magic of ML.
So it's obvious why we
jumped at the opportunity
to collaborate with Mars,
Inc. on an AI-driven recipe
with Maltesers.
Our own Sarah Robinson explore
the relationship between AI
and baking in order to
whip up something really,
really special.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.